D thank you for having me oh absolutely
I'm such a fan of you we're going to get
to it I'm supposed to wait till the
second half but I I'm very excited about
talking about giselda I'm gonna hold off
I'm gonna ask you because you just went
to London right I love lond just went to
London and Madrid oh and now in New York
and tomorrow I go to bota Colombia and
then I go to Miami oh God I know no yeah
I quit touring I know I want to but I
can't no I'm excited so you know I'm
grateful that I get to do this with you
know with this TV show that I really
love doing and that I'm so proud of but
it's I'm exhausted at 51 it's not the
same at 41 it's not the same so Formula
One race you were there in Vegas with
your son right are youall ENT racing um
well my son is obsessed and you know I
get the opportunity to be invited to
things like that and of course he
usually doesn't really care all the
stuff that I do but when he heard that
he was like okay we're going he's like
you're saying yes to that and we did and
it was you know Vegas right there by La
so it was very easy but super exciting
yeah the energy you know the the energy
the men you
know go you it's a lot going on that
weekend in Vegas so it's really fun you
should go yeah oh I've been to Vegas
quite a bit recently like to Vegas to
the Formula One I I don't know that I've
been to Formula One I think I've only
been to NASCAR if I have been to Formula
One I'm so sorry I'm just not
remembering right now um but I but the
racing in general is is insane have you
ever gone really fast one the cars have
you done it with like a driver before I
did a NASCAR with Jimmy Johnson they
went really fast and I was like I'm good
why for what I don't know I'm not like a
thrill seeker like I did it because they
asked me to and I was working with a
company that they were like it'd be cool
if you could do this I was like all
right I'm usually game and then I was
like this is not me yeah you ever dat it
again no no okay that's I'm just like
why why am I trying to be like all
rebellious like sexy and I'm never I
never aim for
sexy I never that's not but even if you
pay me to get in a car like that I
wouldn't do it now yeah no no it sounds
like but you're I mean well if you pay
me enough
maybe it
depends true for me too um so no but I I
love this about your son because I this
is my dream that one of my children will
cook cuz I don't like cooking and your
son cooks really well as a chef it's
amazing he's so good at it you know he
saved us during the pandemic because if
not we would have starved he decided he
took over and he would give us lunch and
dinner every day we were four people
during the pandemic together in the
house and I think he's he learned even
more than what he knew because he even
started doing like sushi lianes food and
I'm like what he taught himself how to
do it it's amazing yeah um what's like
your proudest moment because there as a
single mom and and you play we're going
to get to the movie um but the series
but um you play um she's a single mom
and the you're you single mom so like
what's your proudest moment cuz it's
hard to be there for everything to hold
down a job to it's super hard and you
know when you're young I was very young
and I'm for example now that I'm 51 I
think we talked about it a little bit
when we were the last time that I saw
you it's like you know I wish I had done
things a little bit you know different
because I didn't know I was young I was
20 years old when Manola when I had
Manola so I was like kind of like
raising myself at the same time so what
I mean I should have been going to
therapy or somebody should have been
guiding me uh but I am so proud that he
turned out amazing and super hardworking
and that he you know that he wants to do
things in life and he's excited about
life I think that's what all mothers you
know wish for yeah and just polite and
respectful I'm like that's my thing I'm
like if anything you can be any of the
things but just kind would be good kind
yeah be kind to to other people and I
mean like I don't have anything bad to
say about my son um so I did a great job
I love it
you got to be proud of that so wait I
want to show a couple old photos of
y'all together so first is this look
look at you oh my God I think that was
in Miami some Halloween or something
well that's a Full Circle you're talking
about a character in Miami in Miami yeah
I remember I think that was around the
time one time like I was dropping him to
school and he turned around and said to
me mom don't forget that tomorrow it's
like the parents uh teacher thing yeah
and I'm like yeah sure I know he's like
and then he was going to close the door
and he turned around and said don't
forget to dress like a
mom I was like I was like I don't even
I'm like wait don't just say that I get
out of the car what does that even mean
my son says things to me about my
wardrobe he literally made me change for
my girl's night out just going out to
dinner he was like oh so you're going to
wear that and I was like damn I was like
well then you're worse than me because
at least I was in my 20s I was like 23
when you told me that you're like I
should be killing it right now no wait
that's me they're Honest Kids I love it
um there's there's also this one though
in his favorite 101 Dalmation Speedo
which is so great like that's where are
yall no that's Columbia I was at the
beach that's my cousin Joi and we're
just like at the you know the local
beach in in Colombia and Manolo there
you know I love it oh I haven't seen
that picture easy to see them small I
know now he's big yeah that was a look
at her new Netflix series for Zelda
which she stars in and executive
producers congratulations on that that's
incredible that scene is very relaxing
oh I've seen other yeah yeah that's more
chill that's like the that's it's like
the call before the storm yeah exactly
it's it's incredible I I want to get
into a couple parts but before we do
like kind of explain the series
everybody well it's a very interesting
uh character because it was a real woman
that existed in the 70s and in the ' 80s
in colia I she became one of the biggest
drug lords in you know in this business
and you know it's not like now now women
can do things like that be to the level
of men but in that era it was really
rare and yes it was unheard and there
there has been in history women that
have been able to do a little bit of
that business but not to the level that
she got to and she got away with it for
so long because nobody was expecting
that it was a woman yeah so there it was
like like I mean paralyzing to me
because to understand that this woman
really existed while she was Raising
four kids yeah and and I'm like why
didn't I ever heard of her I live in
Colombia in that era the 70s the 80s and
90s um my brother was unfortunately part
of the business he got killed in
Colombia and and and I know that that
that character so well how do we none of
us knew about her about her existence
and I started digging in digging in and
there's a lot on her uh there's public
records she was in jail for 22 years I
mean it was a whole disaster wow I think
that's isn't that kind of how they say a
true boss is the one that you don't even
know exist like you know what I'm saying
like a is one that don't even have to
like say it exactly it was a very
difficult story for me to to to
understand because it's a woman and yeah
I'm like how do you connect with that
character too that's a drug lord yes and
you know I feel like women always are
we're protecting we're like you know
surviving and but I did understand her
because I was a woman I was Colombian I
was a single mother like her I mean she
escaped a lot she escaped abused when
she was young I I haven't but I mean
there was a lot of similarities and I
and I I've raised a kid on my own I'm an
immigrant she was an immigrant so there
were a lot of similarities the thing is
that she
went I want to say like she lost her
mind and and did things in this in that
business that were like ruthless yeah
and and she ended not there you know in
a good way yeah I love I love that tease
I love it so I this is incredible you
you look I feel like they only changed
your nose or something I don't know what
they did like they didn't like they
changed are you crazy no I'm saying like
whatever they did though it looks slight
it doesn't look like you know what I'm
saying like when you look at you it
doesn't look was ours here what I'm
saying now here's what I'm saying it
probably took time but what I'm saying
the slight change completely changed
your being like I it was a wig shut up
it was a
wig it was a lot they did a lot to me it
was teeth it was wig it was nose it was
plastic from here to here but what I'm
saying is it looks like no how I'm
saying is they did such a good job that
it looks seamless and you just look like
a different like you you literally look
like you could actually just be this
person in other movies you could have
two careers you
could yes I know you literally look like
you're a different actress like playing
the like you can have a whole different
life that is exactly what I wanted that
reaction and I love that you thought
that it was just a little thing because
that means they did a good job natural
exactly I love too that we just get to
see you in that role like I don't you
know what I'm saying this is such a
departure for Modern Family it's such a
departure for things you know even like
on America Got Talent your personality
in general like it's just such a cool
departure and such a cool Flex for you
like a cool muscle to be able to flex
for everybody well you know I I I was
always worried when I was when I decided
to do it I'm like I I just don't want to
think these I wanted sopia and Gloria
preacher to disappear I didn't want the
audience to say it's like why does
Gloria preacher think that with that
robbert nose she can you know trick us
into that she's a dramatic you know
killer or actress you know it happens
you are yeah but I was worried the whole
time like I was like are they going to
see Gloria preach it in in Gela I mean
no did you see you don't see you at all
this character it's like insane I just
remember going wait what happened what
did they do I don't understand even your
voice is different like every yeah the
way the way I walked I had to learn how
to smoke I had to learn um I don't know
if I can say that in here to do cocaine
but yeah but not real cocaine of course
fake cocaine like thing but I I'm I was
50 years old and I had never even
touched a cigarette so I had to learn
how to hold it it was like yeah it was
that was stressing me because you know
people that have seen smoking their
whole life they're just it's like an
extension of their of their arm and I I
was at the beting like yeah well if you
were doing this then you're used to
smoking something like
no I'm just messing with you all right
let's take another break grisela
premieres tomorrow on Netflix y'all have
got to check it
[Music]
[Applause]
out thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home